[Music]
fellow meemers that's right I'm changing
name you're not no longer bros means
serfs everybody meme stirs meme family
meme army meme special people meme no
gender binary group of association that
appreciate means that's what we are
everybody hope you guys can enjoy this
new title that I given you our signature
move is going to be the brofist first
beam everybody oh my god it's been so
long since I've done this I'm like how
do i frickin do this guy's the Obama has
entered the hemisphere we knew that of
ones aliens attack they would not be
pleasant but finally we have evidence
you Bhama exists open your goddamn eyes
for once and for all
we don't know who struck first you Obama
or them but we know that we are the ones
that scorch the sky I know what you're
thinking my god I'm actually kind of
aroused don't look into his eyes for too
long
you could lose your virginity yo mama
just when you thought Obama was gone yo
bomber enters the battlefield
yo bomber is your mama this is how it
all came to be
yo bomber president that's what we
thought that's what we thought your
Bible was president and then the sky got
scorched into Y Obama no God I'm looking
at him oh god I'm looking at him oh god
I can't take my eyes off guys please
your Baba
Blake's why is his meme still going if I
reviewed it this and more on the next
episode of meme review
[Music]
so what is Obama and Yoda have been
common really honestly if you think
about it I know it sounds like I'm
joking and that this is just a meme but
think about it they're both green
they're both in the president they both
take part of the Star Wars franchise and
they both name contains Obama Yoda Obama
do I need to lay out any more
straight-up facts and logics for you
fellas have you not been studying
critical thinking I see how it is I bet
you're one of those people that believe
that you Bhama isn't real cringe
[Music]
[Applause]
oh well my way I went my way I went that
way I'm starting to understand the mean
that it's kind of slightly racist
undertones booster boys buster boys that
was a joke that was a joke everybody
that was a joke 100% joke joke it's a
joke
it was a joke it was a joke I don't even
think he's racist that was a joke it's a
farce damn it stop it Vox media it was a
joke
your bombers values I haven't done a
background check and it would just be
clear his values and ideas art does not
necessarily align with mines I'm just
merely reviewing him this is just me
giving a critical standpoint on this
person and it's not intended to go any
further than that so please do not get
radicalized
by Obama or should I call you Darth
Sidious man it
there's no info about this meme like who
made this mean you know what I don't
want to know I don't want to know oh
that is hot
that is high oh my god oh my freaking
gosh that's so cool
20:18 is this crazy we had not just oh
Bunga but now we have your bomber what's
next bro bro bro buh buh mah brobama oh
my god imagine like bro bomber like a
really buff version of Obama like an
ultimate bro like a really big Chad
bomber chad bomber could be good that
could be now what if what about whole
rooster of obama like 250 of them and
then you can catch them and make you all
your Obama let's fight each other that
would be pretty cool Obama mine
[Music]
okay so this is how it all went down huh
I see here he is that's a bomb I'm
meeting up with Oh
oh god damn these Eddas are so good stop
using copyrighted music meme stirs my
fellow memes sir
I cannot benefit with their revenue out
of your work if you put all this link it
anyway cuz it was so great oh oh [ __ ]
I'm sorry excuse me
oh shoot your bar my sin smash oh my god
you've got the knuckles haven't seen him
in years
honestly looking back in retrospect it
should have been obvious that Obama is
your bomber the evidence was pretty
clear I mean he basically spelled it out
for us oh my god he's right freakin
there I mean how could we I miss that he
was right there clear mainstream media
bias that favors Obama and try and hide
the lies about your mama I'm gonna give
the Obama Mima next meme everybody next
up we have the Will Smith in rewind meme
that's right everybody let's have a look
at YouTube rewind 2018 but every time
it's cringy the video ends guys I don't
know if you knew this but the YouTube
rewind 20:18 was really bad I don't know
if anyone said this before but it was
not good when you browse by haunt now
that's hot good mean really good meme at
least we gonna have some some good memes
out of this now Will Smith who's a
youtuber a fellow youtuber he's become a
meme what if Will Smith hosts meme
review oh wow things that will never
happen it was pretty clear that this
moment with Will Smith then the YouTube
rewind was gonna become a meme just for
I feel like they even knew themself you
rewind that it was gonna become a meme
oh that's hot
that is huzzah that is hot man you don't
just go oh that's hot
the thing I'm looking at over there I
really approve of that thing over there
please so make this into a meme guys
because I honestly just like what's over
there you know I'm saying they can't be
that stupid
god dammit that's odd
I think I prefer my version has a little
bit more passion in it I think I am a
better actor than Will Smith I'm sorry I
Willie oh except that it's about three
times that many now smithy I'm sorry
dude the vein in his face though
honestly are we gonna talk about that or
we're just moving on we're just moving
on okay I think that's better
that is how it's uh it's very hot good
joke what else is hot event yeah I do
like that one
what else can Will Smith say is heart
fires oh that's hot creating friction
friction everybody off releasing energy
oh that's hot what is that I've never
seen that what are these some planters
that is hot Oh God
Oh God abort abort abort right now I
bought right now on board I'm calling
right Alert red alert Red Alert red
alert stop step never again that is not
hi oh I guess Will Smith really likes a
lot of things oh that's hot that's hot
ah is that what my leg swank'd what that
freak well now I know at least goddamnit
Will Smith why didn't you call me
Oh
another micro meme that came out of this
which is rewind time celebrity makes
racist homophobic tweets Twitter users
10 years later its rewind time tries to
sleep my brain may I offer a selection
of your worst memories from the last 10
years me no please don't do this
my brain its rewind time oh god I'm so
glad I'm not the only one I mean maybe
it's obvious because damn it why can't
my brain not just let go of these
goddamn memories it's almost like I
thought about them so many times that
the synapses in my brain just
immediately as soon as it relaxes makes
these connections just because I
inadvertently practice to make these
associations that I don't want to make
why is this a doing this to me why is my
brain doing this anyway when you enter
YouTube's trending section its rewind
time because it's trash oh it's trash
get it trash it's trash another micro
meme if you will that came out of
YouTube rewind was there I'm so proud of
this community by Gabi the first time I
tried to suck my own man I am so proud
of this community the wordsmith mean
gets a - I don't know it's pretty [ __ ]
next meme everybody are you guys ready
for this one
it's gonna be epic and we've already
seen some foreshadowing what's it gonna
be is together
it's the Gabi you've probably seen this
meme it came from a genius rap video I
guess they do all their songs now as
well is this channel that usually
features rappers who break down the
lyrics of their songs and explain the
meaning behind the lyrics but for some
reason they decided to add in ex Viners
which is basically the equivalent if I
went on the rap genius and and broke
down the lyrics for lasagna
they even had one of lily ponds I used
to like a guy right I used to like
someone else right right I did that
right I did this thing right
that's thumbnail right there why genius
my favorite one is rich shade yeah by
the way when I pull up in that Maserati
I don't
I'm not really into cars and you sounded
cool on this let's go back to the topic
at hand we have Gabby Gabby Hannah is
that her name why should you have two
names laying in the bed that I made
guess I'm not surprised honestly
obviously nobody else is here with me in
this bed dan that's deep
hahaha that's deep I'm so glad I'm so
glad I finally get the breakdown in the
lyrics of Gabby Hannah as a monster cuz
I will I've always wondered what she
meant when she said laying on the bed
all alone thank God thank you so much
for this hanging in my head that you
stayed and I hope you'll miss me
eventually so I think what she meant
with his nose I'm not sure but I think
it's like she's praying that someone
stayed I think that she's hoping that
that person will miss her but eventually
and with time you know I don't want to
you know put words in her mouth but I
I'm just gonna guess that's just my
hours of deep analysis that I come up
with I'm a type of person who if I love
you and I care about you and you're part
of my life I never want to lose you
damn that's a pretty original trait yeah
you know generally when you love someone
you don't really care about that person
at all so that's nice to see that Gabby
has that opinion about things that's not
really unique in there for refreshing
output on life okay let's just get to
the mean part I don't have time for this
just sing the part Gabby just sing the
part Gabby just sing the part what
happened there I have a couple theories
we're gonna jump into it guys but let's
just listen to that one again
[Music]
it's baby on my mom
so this it's kind of random that this
became a meme I guess but for some
reason that would this is enough for a
bee mr. blow-off in 2018 and death we
have these beautiful parodies of this
let's just jump into it guys maybe I'll
be bad yeah and you can be is the
monster okay we're gonna end that meme
there everybody
gabbi's monster meme get set three I
guess I don't know it's not that great
but most importantly electrocuting my
muscles to force me to damn I am so
proud of this community can we get a
shout-out to all women that was it for
this week's main review hope you had fun
guys if you had fun remember to smash
like and subscriber now it's 76 77
million subscribers thank you guys so
much I love you guys so much thank you
so much thank you very much really
appreciate you guys so much thank you so
much why can't I not be sincere for one
goddamn second thank you guys so much
thank you guys thank you guys thank you
guys so much thank you guys so much
[Music]